now your dad has popped up on the
spin-off already yeah what advice did he
give you before you dived into doing
reality TV you know he really didn't
have much to say about it actually I
think he was you know very much
supportive he's been very supportive the
entire way through he knows what it's
like to live in the public eye so I
think that you know it's great that he
you know there to kind of like guide me
throughout but like you really just let
me you know handle it and then and you
know to dive right in your parents have
really just let you and your sister be
who you are and celebrate who you are
it's really great that they've allowed
us to kind of just you know go out in
the world and make it our own
we got to give EJ the credit because
he's he's really terrific that camera
loves them and now his baby sister ELISA
is a breakout star as well but mommy
manager over here has done a wonderful
job what do you say honey no I'm so
proud of them I mean EJ carved 'sister
himself you know he did this he went out
there for it he you know and he's you
know making his own imprint as he says
you know getting out of Daddy's shadow
so we're very proud we're all really
close which is amazing I'm like you know
she's always been my number one
cheerleader so it's good to have her in
my corner no matter you know what the
odds are I mean he's just being himself
and doing his thing and the world is
loving it and we love it you know and
this one's right behind him you know
yeah she's on the show and she's a great
talent also and I mean I couldn't be
more proud mom so I told them you know
I'm retiring from doing my genes and I'm
gonna be their momager